hey everyone I'm so excited because this
is my first ever google shopping video
so it's basically a shop Abul youtube
video this video is made in part for
YouTube's awesome stuff week and for
your must-have Monday I've got one of
the phantom drones for the video that I
made who have YouTube I'm in this really
cool fun little video so you guys should
check that out
link in the description right now I'm
hiking up to the top of this mountain to
show you guys what I've got on my back
this is the Phantom 3 professional drone
and it does 4k video which isn't me
pretty exciting hopefully we got some
good shots hopefully I don't lose the
drone somewhere I'm gonna get the sunset
yes I'm sitting coy
and you're facing a block maybe I'm not
sure like I can't see either uh hey guys
so we we did a little calculating of the
time a little wrong it's completely
pitch black oh my gosh it's actually
really cool
oh is it yeah and terrifying